The Joe Rogan Experience
they're on balloons
why wouldn't they be Chinese and he
doesn't believe in satellites on
satellites they're just on balloons
they've always have been and they still
satellites around balloons
look at the time kids
12 15. did they just shoot more down
yeah the shot went down in uh Canada and
uh there's there's like two that they've
shot down like recently we can't have
that they don't know they don't know
what they are there's some sort of a
surveillance device I talked to an
unmanned drone talked to Dan Crenshaw we
have Tick-Tock um Dan crenshaws me on
the intelligence committee he couldn't
say much but Dan Crenshaw said like the
truth is probably a lot less sexy than
people think right people wanted to be a
UFO yeah also it's definitely not also I
wanted to be that that'd be great alien
ware
what if they're dumb aliens they like
fight face first they think they
overestimate us they think the binders
knew about it like NSA knew about it and
then when the guy caught it on his long
range lens they said oh [__] then they
were like we have to do something did
you hear that they said that there was
Chinese spy Balloons with Trump but they
didn't tell him yes Madison said that
you know how hilarious it is they know
he would shoot that [__] just imagine if
you hold ever information from the
[__] president because you're worried
he's going to say or do something they
did that all the time apparently
a lot of people said that they were
afraid is that even legal well that
compromises us is that even legal like
what is what are the laws in terms of
like what you're supposed to tell the
president of the United States I mean he
he is the leader if it's not a national
security uh emergency apparently because
you need to know you know everything you
should probably know that yeah they hate
Chinese spy balloons of habit regardless
for one second do I think that's a
Chinese spy balloon not have MSM is
saying that right if CNN is like oh it's
something else Fair Point do you think
they put it up there to make Brian look
good I don't know what maybe I don't
know what they're so that they could say
oh China's [__] with us and then we
could do things to China you think
China's gonna launch a [__] balloon
across the Pacific Ocean I don't think
China might be maybe Huawei does maybe
Huawei is still mad that we pulled their
phones [__] you yeah
if you want to see I don't believe if
you want to see something [__]
fascinating there's a there's a show on
uh I think it's Amazon you can get it
it's called The Bureau and it's in
French right but it's about how the
French intelligence agency actually
works and I watched that [__]
sometimes yes but I'm telling you I
watched it and I went I went to watch
how like enjoyed but I know
what's it on Hulu I think it's on Amazon
but to watch how ingenious the
intelligence agencies are like whatever
you think you know and then you watch
that even if even if it's only half
truth you watch that whoever wrote that
knew a lot about don't you think that's
the case why you know that's one of the
things that Putin said like when when he
talked about like he's been through
three different presidents like
everybody has these big Ideas until they
get into office that's one thing in the
office yeah they all do the same thing
exactly they all do the same thing and
they follow the orders he said men in
dark Suits come and visit them they're
like mine they're wearing a suit like
mine they come in they tell them how
things are run and that's that's the
reality calendar don't believe that
though I I think that that's to
conspiratorial well no I think that the
NSA
um probably eavesdrops on Americans and
that's illegal what are you saying man
you think your phone is listening to you
[__] what's wrong with you yeah right I
I think Snowden talked about that and I
think that's true I think there are a
lot of laws that are bent and broken
probably look in the name of X Y and Z
no question about it yeah yeah and you
know I think that they probably can
write some of it off to National
Security but it gets a little stability
but it gets a little sketchy when you
find out that they're doing things to
set people up like the governor Whitmer
thing where they they had 14 people that
were trying to kidnap her and 12 of them
were FBI informants oh that's right was
that the lady in Michigan yeah and the
two guys that were like they were like
we didn't even really want to do this
they were dumb dudes that they talked
into it and they've done that before
with people that 19 year old kid they
talked into detonating a fake bomb they
they radicalized him got a real
vulnerable dumb kid radicalized him gave
him a bomb told him the plan to game his
cell phone to call I was gonna detonate
the bomb he did it and then they
arrested him Jesus they gave him all the
stuff they told them to do it like then
he did it and they're like ah we gotcha
stop this terrorist plot